[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voir les enfants qui a vu le ciel ce
soir voit pas trop le mot ni sea wind
north car c'est l'été et les étoiles
brillent une fête où l'on pense aux
vacances qui approchent
pour le ch
joue hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
[Musique]
encore hitler un coquelicot
annonce que nous fait de blagues
solo bonsoir mon kayak
du nul aux défunts
ce n'est pas moi regardez aussi j'en ai
reçu dix doigts ça fait drôle c'est trop
jolie les fleurs mais moi j'ai le roi et
je veux gagner nicolas se joue avec toi
mais malgré attaque lit qu il faut faire
un bouquin de fleurs son cv il ya déjà
tout ça
nous jouerons tout à l'heure pour
l'instant
faisons un piqueur tiens voilà j'ai vu
le loup du blé c'est formidable
deux pros
j'ai de plus en plus extraordinaires
moi je vais fermer cette fenêtre chamois
et je veux gagner calme-toi nicolas elle
coûte si tu ferme la fenêtre nous ne
serons pas qu'à lancer ses fleurs
cachons nous attendons on verra bien
d'ici là le bouquet est terminée il est
magnifique cachons nous et le faisons
pas de bol y
un mois il faut que java moi j avais
[Musique]
je viens d'un
petit bout de temps ce qu'était jati des
devenu il m'a fait perdre une partie de
cas je suis contente de voir ses traits
qui nous a lancé tout sifflé
et leurs chômeurs évidemment avec toutes
les fleurs qu'elle a transporté pour le
nestor adoma
parigny jolie juliette pas
[Musique]
si tu avais vu trois que j'avais un
rouge ou dors tu peux jouer près de
juliette a donné nous
donner
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas trop juliette est arrivé tout le
monde est content alors oui elle a
apporté des tra de flore à route mon bon
nounours bonne nuit des enfants embrasse
bien fort vous parents et feux de
poubelles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]